yeah yeah you know the joke at this
point there's more stuff there's always
more stuff in breath of the wild if you
want to keep seeing new things you know
what to do just let us know with the
like without further ado let's jump
right into it
many players know that lionels have a
secret ability to retreat and teleport
back to their territory if they're too
far away from home but this teleport is
never used to attack you
wait a second uh well this lynel near to
banta bridge stable can go on the attack
and teleport to you as several points
off its plateau by repeatedly parrying
it until it falls off then heading out
of its arena while it's warping it will
chase you down for a follow-up fight for
players who have fought tons of lynels
this can be a nice change of scenery and
did you know that with frame perfect
timing you can mount and teleport with
the lynel
when completing the final trial of the
sword you will approach these monks to
receive the fully powered up master
sword what you might not know is that by
clipping inside you can meet them face
to face
and they even have the wake option
unfortunately it doesn't actually do
anything but the fact that they have its
interaction at all is pretty interesting
also you can then pull the master sword
from the inside which looks pretty
amazing with all the shrine's light
particles
[Music]
did you also know that these mugs all
represent the seven sages poses
specifically from ocarina of time
[Music]
and all four great plateau monks hand
signs combined together to become the
triforce symbol
did you know that the entirety of hyrule
has water underneath this is how
developers created lakes and rivers by
simply pulling up the water level above
ground where it was needed to create
bodies of water this was supposedly done
to help with the game's performance and
on the same subject the developers used
special editing tools to manually create
hyrule by hand these were the tools used
in its creation these icons include all
sorts of brushes and height map tools
many of which players have seen the
basics of when clipping out of bounds
[Music]
during development the game's executable
file isn't simply called breath of the
wild.exe it has a code name breath of
the wild was called you
king.rpx and other reads and zelda games
were codenamed by playing cards as well
such as wind waker hd called sea king
ocarina of time 3d by queen a link
between worlds as jack majora's mask 3d
as joker and triforce heroes as alice
it's possible that all this is a partial
reference to alice in wonderland
there are a ton of entries in the
compendium all requiring you to take a
picture of the item first and there is
also a shortcut way to purchase all of
them but either way forces you to do one
thing first take a picture of this
sunshroom
you have to do this so either way your
compendium will never have a default
picture of a sunshroom but it does exist
this is the default sunshroom photo
called item mushroom c
did you know that you can destroy
pebblets with your flurry rushing body
your rush down itself when colliding
with pebblets has enough momentum to
destroy them this won't work if you're
too close
in the giants forest there's a sleeping
hynox surrounded by trees and it often
picks up one of those pre-cut logs
around it to pummel you with but the
developers misplaced one one log is
found underground floating on the water
below
there's a cut scene in the age of
calamity dlc that has zelda cooking up a
nice stew this is a real recipe that can
be recreated in breath of the wild with
the initial ingredients of a hylian
shroom raw meat fresh milk and hyrule
baths making a delicious meat and
seafood fry
but was instead ruined by adding a dash
of monster extract which then turned it
into a monster stew
[Music]
judging by their reaction that doesn't
sound very tasty anymore
did you know that high knox can swim
it's not as straightforward as just
being able to swim though they have a
unique animation of swimming itself and
being stunned while swimming not only
that they have similar ai to horses to
look for the closest shoreline to get
back onto solid ground
and if it can't find any nearby
shoreline within one minute it will
drown with a unique animation and sound
for it
the sound effect used is called giant vo
cry1 okay now i feel bad
did you know that you can make soft
boiled eggs with hot water okay you
probably knew that one but how about
campfire eggs with fire okay that's too
easy how about cooking eggs with a bmos
laser
yeah this one's weird but beemo's laser
has the ability to cook eggs other
ingredients just get destroyed or
ignored so this is purely an egg thing
don't ask me why
this is a subtle detail you might not
have noticed but all shikas are
completely unfazed by rain while most
other races run for cover while it's
raining all chica don't care or even
prefer it if you talk to dorian orcado
while it's raining they'll explain how
shiga outfits keep the rain off ward off
lightning and are still comfortable when
wet you can see pokongo always stay
outside rather than hide inside the
stable with the other hylians as he's
more in his element in the rain some
players still don't know that feeding
enemies isn't just a distraction
technique it actually heals them
do you actually understand how guardians
work guardians have a hidden rule you
may or may not have noticed their
movement is dependent on which direction
link is facing
this is why many new players have such a
hard time against guardians because
being a coward and running with your
back turned only makes them chase down
your front side and make the situation
worse once you understand this rule
aiming a guardians becomes painless
by simply looking in the direction you
want them to be they'll literally line
up their eye right in your crosshairs
for you
guardians are also capable of attacking
your enemies if pulled far away enough
from their home area
if any enemy attack strikes them they'll
switch targets and hit them back
did you know they could backflip out of
a talus's left hand punch its other
attacks can't be dodged this way
previously i've shown the random patch
of lava near the colosseum but did you
know about the secret patch of ice water
in the lost woods
using active arrow smuggling and a
campfire you can head off the beaten
path near the entrance of mog holland
shrine and you'll find an invisible
patch of normal water with small patches
of ice water beneath the grass you can
see link taking damage and its
thermometer freezes up
alright now we're on to end game boss
stuff so heads up for any new players
several episodes ago i showed how yiga
foot soldiers while teleporting used
actual ninjutsu by summoning cursed
hylian letters representing the kuji
incantation maz koshia as a real shika
monk can do this as well but his version
is in shika instead of hylian pretty
interesting lore implications here
there's a couple of old hidden tricks
when fighting mod koshia such as
tracking down the real monk between the
clones when he duplicates by simply
pulling out your camera to scan the real
one
and if you're ever overwhelmed while
fighting moz koshio just pull out a
banana this little monk can't deny a
fresh banana
[Music]
dark beast ganon most players can agree
that he is pretty much a pushover i
wouldn't even call this a fight
what are you even shooting at man but
what if he upped the ante just a tad
with guardians lots of guardians by
kiting guardians to the center of hyrule
then disabling them so they stay
permanently loaded and don't move you
can collect a small army of guardian
stalkers then by beating calamity ganon
while they're still loaded dark beast's
ganon will load in with the surrounding
guardian army unlocking them with bomb
arrows or other means makes them fight
link alongside dark b's ganon for an
epic battle for some reason this looks
way more canon story wise for a final
fight against ganon take some notes
nintendo
hopefully you'll learn a new thing or
two because breath of the wild is truly
a never-ending game we also have a
playlist that includes other breath of
the wild videos we still make about
topics not mentioned in this series so
keep it here on gamespot
[Music]